[Music]
hello welcome to film independent
presents virtual edition uh my name is
matt warren i'm the senior manager of
digital content here at film independent
and before we get started with today's
very awesome q a for the new showtime
documentary the real charlie chaplin
i want to take a minute to shout out a
couple of our
program's loyalist uh supporters so
thank you to our lead sponsor the
hollywood foreign press association
and to our online screening partner
vision media
and with that i'm very excited today to
be chatting with one of the co-directors
behind this uh
incredible new documentary which i'm uh
sure
you all just got done watching and
enjoying
i am here with mr uh james spinney how
are you james i'm good thank you matt
it's a pleasure to talk to you
now i think i think everyone watching
this will have just seen the film but
uh we're here to talk about your
film uh with your code of director the
real charlie chaplin
and
people could probably guess from the
title that this is a documentary about
the life and the work of uh charlie
chaplin
[Music]
once won't be insecure with a childhood
like his
i stopped new york
he's in
chaplain once said all the adulation is
not for me it's for the little man
[Music]
thought anybody loved him he never
believed it
he was always acting
he didn't want people to know the real
successful charlie a young age
it usually destroys them the internet
makes them
but i had no idea who the man was
i wanted to start by just kind of
opening up a general conversation
and asking you in your opinion what was
it about chaplin's sort of talents as an
artist and a performer that
sort of meshed so well with cinema in
its early days you know what were what
were the factors that made charlie
chaplin such a phenomenon as this new
medium was dawning
yes that's such an interesting question
um
i mean chaplin's life to some degree
seems so intertwined with film like he
was born in 1889 um in the film we look
at you know one of the films that uh
that came out in 1889 a thomas edison
film and it's this sort of hazy
impressionistic blur
um but then as chaplain grew up um in
the 1890s in south london
that's the point where we first started
to see south london on film and um and
represented and then as chaplain goes to
hollywood in the 1910s um you know max
senate has created keystone studios who
um who kind of launched chaplin um but
but when he first steps onto screen in
1914 um films were just beginning to
spread across the world um
and then quickly within a couple of
years by 1916 chaplin is
the most famous person in the world um
and and not at the most famous famous in
a way that that hadn't been possible um
before because of this new mass media
technology which was um
meaning that people
from all backgrounds of of all languages
were kind of falling in love with
chaplin through his tramp character
um and i think that's a really
interesting quality in terms of what it
was about chaplin um because you know at
the time silent film this this new art
form was seen as um as something akin to
visual esperanto that's a term that you
hear at the time so there's this sense
that film
can be watched by people from all
backgrounds can be sitting side by side
in cinemas across the world all watching
the same film and laughing and kind of
losing themselves and so there's this
kind of liberation of identity that
comes with with uh with silent film and
chaplain is kind of the emblem of that
because um you know he's this he plays
this nameless tramp character who kind
of um comes from nowhere and seems to be
going nowhere um he's constantly playing
with identity with with gender with
sexuality um he's upending authority in
class so he's this very fluid character
um
who also just communes with the audience
like we talk in the film about um
chaplin's eye contact the fact that he
he um he looks straight at us from
across the screen um he does that from
his first film as the tramp or the first
one that's released kid auto races in
the first moment he steps on the screen
he's looking at us and kind of building
this rapport with us and i think that
intimacy that he strikes up with the
audience um which you still feel uh you
know over 100 years later when you watch
them you feel this crackle as he as he
looks at you it's kind of flirtatious
and mischievous when he does that um and
watching his films today you know we
found that
they felt fresh and subversive even over
a century later um and also felt like a
type of cinema that you know we don't
see today um
and so it's it's it's very hard to i
think to break down exactly what it is
about chaplin and we spent a long time
in the film looking at um
at his costume um and the fact that uh
though he claims to have assembled this
costume in a in a kind of moment of
panicked inspiration there are lots of
other people who claim that they got
their first and and then there are lots
of other people who imitate him and rip
him off and kind of pirate him and
that's um a bit of a wild goose chase
but what i think you get from it is the
fact that though everyone else can wear
the the hat and the moustache and carry
the cane even do the walk they don't
have what chaplin has they don't have
this this quality which is so hard to
define but which is so
so obvious when you watch his films
and you know you include in your film
you sort of re count this sort of mass
delusion that i was familiar with by
after reading the glen david gold book
sunny side which is also about chaplin
in part where
uh all of these
people um you know thought that
chaplin was coming to them or that they
had seen chaplain there was sort of a
moment of mass delusion where chaplain
sort of manifested himself
in all of these different areas and i i
had uh assumed that was a literary
invention on
one day the gold's part until i looked a
little further into it and found out
that that was something that actually
had some precedent in reality
could you uh maybe describe that odd
phenomenon a little bit because i think
that goes into
what we're talking about about just the
mass uh reach of this character
and this artist at this time
absolutely well yeah i'm so glad you
brought up sunnyside as well which is a
beautiful book and which kind of takes
this event um from 19
i think it's december 1914 uh where
supposedly on a single day chaplain was
being um was being seen in parts in
places all across america simultaneously
um so there were sightings of him in uh
in train stations and there were crowds
gathering and then there were people in
hotel lobbies who um who who were paging
him and there was something happening on
this day
and in um sunnyside uh the wonderful
book um it's kind of dramatized to the
point where you know he's seen by a
lighthouse keeper um
in a dinghy i think in our film we
played a bit straighter and we just used
that um
that day to kind of look at
what seems to be happening at this
moment um you know silent film as we've
said is was is a is a very new
phenomenon at that time and so there
seems to be some kind of
mass hysteria as you say going on which
people call charlie mania chaplinitis
um the chaplain craze um you know it has
all sorts of resonances i think with
mania um 50 years later um
and
it manifests in all sorts of ways it
manifests in these um extraordinary
contests you get where people are
dressing up as chaplain and the big kind
of rumor um or joke maybe was that
chaplin entered a chaplain contest and
came 30th i think um
and um
and as well as that yeah there's there's
he's being pirated his films are being
re-edited um and repackaged um and
stolen there's people like
charles aplin um who whose real name was
um charles amador um who was a mexican
actor who was cr who was um releasing
sort of imitation chaplain films
and amador's defense when uh chapman
sues him for this is that uh that he
wasn't actually imitating chaplin he was
imitating billy west who was a famous
chaplain impersonator
so
you know that sense of of of where
things begin and end um that kind of
swirling sense of um
of just adulation for him that was was
really taking
height at that point um
i think i said i said 1914 maybe it was
1916 actually that this all took off
because that was the moment i think
where his fame really took a new leap um
and and he really kind of by that point
hundreds of millions of people across
the world were regularly watching
chaplain films so this wasn't just an
american phenomenon you know in france
he was called charlotte
he was charlie in parts of africa he was
carlitos in spain
um sidakwa in um in south africa um the
japanese called him um professor alcohol
sensei
um so yeah it was this international
phenomenon um and for us i think
then the big question is well what
psychologically does that do to you if
uh
if you're uh
at the center of all that um and if and
also i think in terms of chapman's
relationship with his character which
had made him so famous which which
obviously drew so much on his own life
on his insecurities and his humiliations
um
but which uh which had now catapulted
him into this unprecedented fame and
interestingly chaplin um supposedly said
and we quote this in the film
um all the adulation's not for me it's
for the little man well that actually
goes into my next question which
one of the very interesting elements of
this this film that i found watching it
is that it's about
um
the whole of chaplin's sort of life and
career and
you know chaplain is synonymous with
this one character that he created which
is iconic in the literal sense of the
word in its visual presentation but you
do a very
uh
you get you guys as filmmakers do a
really great job of sort of
contextualizing that character within
the entirety of his career
and showing uh how chaplin's career was
both
bigger than just this one character but
also as you were just saying how this
one character sort of subsumed
everything
sort of ultimately so
was that
was that sort of a very conscious choice
to sort of contextualize
the tramp character and make a
distinction between
that and uh chaplin as a writer director
filmmaker who had this sort of larger
career and more stuff he did
yeah well thank you for um for saying
that because
that for us was i think one of the big
puzzles in terms of the interface
between chaplain and the tramp um
and
i think also because
um
we sensed very early on that this gulf
between
the
the sense of identification and intimacy
that people felt with chaplin um through
his presence on screen through the
things that we've talked about this you
know this rapport that he creates with
the audience through breaking the fourth
wall for example and just like you know
just how brilliant he is and how how
kind of loving i think um his films
start to become with things like the kid
in terms of
you know the emotion that starts to
creep in which of course is is mining
his own um traumas and humiliations you
know in the chaplains sort of revisiting
the separation that he experienced from
his mother at a young age and so i think
um
to some degree we were we were always
really amazed at how
when when chaplain kind of made it when
he when he had this huge studio and this
army of people at his disposal he kept
sort of journeying backwards and
journeying inwards
and revisiting those south london
streets that he'd left and rebuilding
those streets in his hollywood studio
you know the attic room that he lived in
with his mother um is so similar to the
attic room in the kid um yes
it was really striking yeah
absolutely
thank you yeah
um
and and you see it as well in um the
gates of kennington park um where
chaplain met for a date with his first
love um that's so strikingly similar to
the the the the gates the park the park
gates of city lights um so this sense of
returning and circularity um
is is is is just sort of key i think to
the trump character you know the trump
the trump um
chapman says about the costume that the
tramp wants to be dignified but his
shoes won't let him you know he's
constantly humiliating himself and kind
of trying to be uh
sort of um
somebody but he he can't it's built into
the costume it's sort of central to the
whole
starting point of the character i think
that's so interesting when you start to
understand the the traumas and
humiliations that chaplain experienced
as a child you know he talks a lot in
his autobiography about wearing certain
clothes and being embarrassed by those
clothes as a child so then for him to
create this character in this costume
where that's that's just so central to
it as well as the the endless gags about
hunger and food that you see in chaplain
films you're never far away from from a
gag involving food um which of course
resonates so strongly when you realize
how hungry chaplin was and effie wisdom
his childhood friend who we hear from in
the film talks a lot about hunger and
the hunger that chaplain experienced so
i think in answer to your question i
think it was it was this sense that
perhaps the for us the the moments that
we felt most
was closest to chaplin and that we felt
that he was he was being most vulnerable
was through his work it was through his
films it was through the tramp and it's
interesting that
um there's this kind of fairy tale
quality to the fact that by playing this
character that's replaying these these
um these pains of his childhood he's
catapulted into something that's so far
removed from that experience where where
he's living he's now the highest paid
entertainer in the world and the most
famous person in the world um and
suddenly he's in these highly respected
circles and living in beverly hills in
this
huge mansion um and i think that sense
of him always going back but also being
in this entirely new space where it
seems to some degree that and
reinventing himself as well you know we
hear from his childhood friend that he
used to have this very thick cockney
accent but when we hear from him in the
1960s he's got this very elevated voice
so there's this constant reinvention
that he's going on there's going on with
him off screen even when on screen he's
constantly returning to to poverty um
and hunger um and and that felt very
interesting to us and it seems like
chapman put a lot of defenses up in in
his um
in his
life off screen um even though his films
are so
open and transparent and vulnerable like
you know the people who knew him best
said that he was always acting and
always performing and always on show um
and and rather heartbreaking you know at
the end of the film we hear from from
his uh his children many of whom you can
feel their yearning to connect with him
and this sense of distance that they
felt um you know his daughter jane says
i grew up with the icon but i had no
idea who the man was so i think that
that's sort of
that strange paradox between him being
universally known and loved and but also
so hard to reach and with sort of the
puzzle of the film
and you know you you speak you just
mentioned sort of a bit of the distance
between him and
some of his children and that and
you know this is a very all-encompassing
uh biography and
you know you would you would call it you
know a warts and all it doesn't shy away
from the sort of more problem aspects of
his personal life or
some of the things he was involved with
and
you know it's a very honest portrait and
i'm wondering
you know sometimes when
you're a biographer whether in film or
literature or anything else and you're
trying to do a sort of um like warts and
all portrait of someone it can sometimes
become all warts
no portrait but
i think this is very respectful and uh
admiring obviously of of the the parts
of his life and career that that
deserved admiration um while being
honest about who he was and i wonder if
you could talk about sort of striking
the right balance between
you know
incorporating some of that messier stuff
and not letting it overwhelm the rest of
what you're talking about when you're
talking about chaplin
well thank you yeah i mean that balance
um was something that we were
very
conscious of throughout the making of
the process and obviously in so many
ways it's um
it's a huge challenge in terms of just
the scope of of a film like this you
know it covers chaplains 88 year life um
and um and we're trying to tell what is
one of the great rags to riches stories
but also encompasses this huge body of
work um and which is very i mean um
heartbreaking and frustrating in terms
of what not to include in terms of his
work as well like you know whole there
have been great documentaries that have
just been made about his life his his
time at mutual or you know a single one
of his films um so it's a huge challenge
always a balance of these different
elements of trying to examine him as a
filmmaker to examine his roots to look
at him as a
as a director as well and i'm not a
director writer producer editor um
composer um and then of course looking
into his personal life and and how he
was as a father and as a husband um
and in that respect as you say um
it's a challenge because
you know chaplain had four wives um and
and and an awful lot of relationships as
well you know he once boasted to have
having had sexual relations with two
thousand
uh women i think um so
um
there's but having said that there's
there's so little testimony to kind of
root these sorts of um that kind of
examination and like um you know of
chapters four wives
we only really have recordings with lita
gray um his first wife mildred harris
isn't on tape anywhere paula goddard did
80 hours of interviews with andy warhol
which um seemed like they might be
fascinating although she's quite cagey
about him from what we've read um she
doesn't give much away but those uh seem
to be locked in um in the warhol
archives and we couldn't we couldn't get
ahold of those um
chapman's fourth wife oona um who very
much was the love of his life and it
seems um
it seems like of all the people who knew
him she understood him best and his
daughter gelding makes that very clear
but she destroyed most of her writing
about him um but we do have a few
interviews with lita gray who is his
second wife and who um
who uh
his divorce from lita gray was was the
most scandalous divorce in hollywood
history at that point and as well as the
most expensive um
and some of the things that she
describes about their relationship are
really troubling you know of course she
was very very young when they um
uh when their relationship began um she
was originally in his film the kid when
she was 12 years old um they married she
became pregnant with his child um around
15 or 16
the the birth dates are unclear because
of certain
birth certificate issues which might
have been falsified um we saw very
complex and that's not going to but um
what really resonated i think with today
for us was um this sense that lita felt
like she found it very hard for her to
get her side of the story across you
know she talks about how
at the time um she didn't feel like
people could reconcile what she was
describing with the character that um
that people knew and loved on screen um
and that um that she was disbelieved
because people idolized charlie um and
some of the revelations that she talks
about the fact that during her their
honeymoon um chaplin suggested that she
should jump off a train um you know that
he threatened her um
and she was very young at the time as
well and so you know all this um
is is really troubling uh you know when
when during the story of course we come
to identify with chaplain and root for
him especially because of the troubling
upbringing that he sort of escaped um
and so yeah holding all these things um
imbalances
was a real challenge and one that we're
very self-conscious of as well as as i
think as male filmmakers and you know
lita talks about how um
how her story had had often been
controlled by men whether it was the um
the lawyers who were kind of in charge
of her divorce case or the people who
co-wrote her her memoirs and kind of
ghost wrote those with her um so um we
hope it's part of a wider conversation
and um and part of a um
a kind of yeah a constant i think
reassessing that that is going on not
just in terms of chaplain i think but
also more societally you know it's clear
that the media um and the establishment
um
were to some degree able to ignore
uh this behavior for a long time and
it's only really when chaplain began
making political statements i think that
um that that kind of protection was was
uh began to change and so i think it's
also to think more interesting to think
more structurally about what's at play
in those sorts of moments
um i i want to ask before we uh move
towards wrapping up here i want to ask
about one very interesting creative
decision i found in the film which is
the fact that the sort of narration that
takes us through
uh the events of chaplin's life is done
sort of in the present tense sort of in
an active present tense rather than the
past tense and it just seems like such a
small detail but i feel like it adds so
much in terms of the tone and the
atmosphere and
sort of the understanding and really the
immersiveness of
this story so i wonder if you could just
talk about that creative decision a
little bit
thank you i'm so glad you picked up on
that because that felt like a real
breakthrough um when we were sort of
scripting the narration um with it was
peter and i and um and our good friend
and brilliant writer ollie um kinderberg
who wrote who wrote the script um and
it felt like i think
we were you know
we were thinking a lot about
chaplin and presentness because i think
there's a kind of meditative aspect to
watching a chaplain film you know he
feel
like uh
you know we've talked about this this
eye contact and this sort of
sense that he creates
also all the film play out in kind of
mostly in wide shots he uses close-ups
very sparingly um and i think because of
that because there aren't many cuts and
uh and the language pace i think you you
experience a different kind of um way of
viewing when you watch when you watch
chaplain films which um which i find
really refreshing in terms of and in
some degrees it was it was hard to to
match that with the edit pace that we
had to um have with the rest of the
archive with uh with the the more sedate
clips of um in terms of how they're shot
so this sense of presentness and being
present um it's very interesting of
course especially with the with chaplin
kind of as we've said kind of reaching
out to us from across time and i think
when you when when we watched chapman
films we felt this sense of time
dissolving and um
that we weren't watching films from over
100 years ago that you know that i think
when you watch a lot of other silent
films and i don't mean to be down on
silent films because i it's been such an
adventure to kind of dive into the
subject more for the last three or four
years and and so often i'm surprised by
just how fresh things feel but i think
chaplain is unusual in quite how fresh
and um
and
modern they feel and how much you just
feel like
you know he's even just some of the
gestures the way that he'll just do
something that you think what people did
that then like
you know in the pawn shop when he's kind
of um he's he's he's been kind of the
clock um and and and uh and to try and
assess whether it's fixable he takes it
apart and unscrews it like it's a can of
tuna takes out all the insides he's
bashing it with a hammer then he's a
doctor kind of and then at the end he's
just like
no sorry there's nothing we can do and
the kind of sheepish way that there's
nothing we can do when i saw that and
you see the people in the 1910s
are just doing that same expression that
you do now that sense of time
yeah exactly so we always felt this
presentness when we were watching
chaplain and we wanted to convey that in
the voiceover and the voiceover which is
which is which is read by the wonderful
narrator pearl mackey um who is very
good at inhabiting this sort of
chaplin-esque quality of being kind of
she kind of code switches and she's sort
of um she's able to kind of i think be
playful i hope and mischievous and and i
think when we heard her what we felt
when we heard her audition for it was
that she kind of feels like hopefully
she's sort of a companion i think for
the audience and she's got her sort of
arm around you is watching watching the
film with you and and hopefully just
sort of observing things with you um and
yes as soon as we switched from the past
tense to the present tense it sort of
changed from i think feeling like a more
conventional narration
um which we were trying to get away from
we didn't want to do a sort of voice of
god type thing we didn't want to have
like a middle-aged man doing it we
wanted to be someone who could yeah who
could be as fluid as as the tramp i
think um in that sense and powell really
kind of brought that through and and
central to that was this breakthrough of
putting it on the present tense and so
i'm so happy that you kind of picked up
on that thank you
i love when you when there's like just a
little twist on something that kind of
makes you hear it in a different way or
like lean in a little bit closer and pay
a little bit more attention
um and you you know you kind of touched
a little bit on on well a lot actually a
lot bit on how
sort of modern
uh chaplin's work feels in comparison to
some of his contemporaries and just to
wrap up here i kind of wanted
your diagnosis of where
you feel charlie chaplin
and his films are at sort of
100 years later currently
in today's sort of cinematic
landscape or understanding or or or just
what where have
where is our understanding and
appreciation for this artist
now and do you think it'll continue to
endure do you think it'll grow contract
i mean i'd be curious to think where
we're at in terms of what we think about
charlie chaplin 100 years later
yes well thank you that's such an
interesting question and even though
we've
just made spent years making this film
it's also one that i sort of feel not
quite qualified to answer in the sense
of like that we've learned so much about
chaplain but but kind of the sort of
relativism of like weighing up of where
he sits in terms of the context of today
is such a huge question that i find it
almost
very hard to get a grasp on us
especially because there's so many ways
to read it as well i think like you know
in terms of chaplain's process it's so
interesting because he was working in a
way that was kind of on very unusual at
the time in terms of him working without
a script and kind of just diving
headlong into
films with just the tiniest of idea just
a fragment of an idea um and kind of
improvising endlessly for years in terms
of the features you know he spends years
on city lights but still doesn't
understand the basic sort of premise of
how this mistaken identity between him
and virginia cheryl the flower girl will
work so that's so interesting because um
you know
bigger productions now i think it would
be kind of unheard of to let someone
just go off and show i mean maybe you
could say i guess like sacha baron cohen
or something could do so i think you
know certain types of comedy perhaps i
think maybe where it's perhaps
responding more and perhaps has like a
slight you know foot in documentary is
interesting um in terms of chaplains
fame it's interesting because
you know to to some degree obviously you
know the internet and media today is is
so international and everything is we're
so interconnected but in another sense i
think the um
the kind of
the the silent quality of the films we
were talking about earlier in terms of
their ability people to identify them
without them being
changed at all really you know because
the intertitles in in chaplains films
are to some degree often um
you know he had this bet with buster
keaton supposedly about who could use uh
uh
you know fewer intertitles in their
films and um so so they're not essential
to understanding them and there's so
much that you get and so i think to that
degree the the kind of international
quality of chaplain's fame and the
adulation that he experienced is it's
quite hard to work out whether or not
there is a direct equivalent to
to today um and then of course yeah how
chaplin's life
it's interesting how chaplin was the
first person to experience
that type of celebrity which hadn't been
possible as we've said before him um so
they you know he
though he he didn't have anyone else to
to kind of
to compare what that must have been like
psychologically um whereas i think now
we're still clearly struggling with our
identification with media and how we
relate to
on online personas and and kind of
avatars and and our presence on um
our kind of virtual presence so it's
interesting that chaplain you know is
very much kind of you can draw a direct
line between
kid or to races and him looking at us
and and those types of conversations
we're having today you know there's so
much nowadays about parasocial relations
and ships and that sort of thing um
and so it's interesting in terms of yeah
the lineage of celebrity um to think
about chaplain and today but then in
terms of the work
you know
pete and i um
you know new chaplains work before we
started the film but we hadn't taken the
the deep dive that we were lucky enough
to have and and the more we've
discovered that you know the the the the
kind of the richer the the work has
become any not just through chaplin you
know through
all the silent films that we've been
lucky enough to kind of watch and so
i feel it's but you know when i look
back to watching them for the first time
when i was a teenager um i always
i had this kind of misapprehension of
silent film as i think a lot of people
did i sort of imagined chaplin as this
kind of
you know hyper slapstick figure who
would kind of be played at the wrong
speed and um um but what i found is as
you've as you've said is this kind of
modern subversive thing which still
feels so fresh today and so you know i i
hope that this film is it plays a tiny
part in being an introduction hopefully
to people who've not seen his films and
and people who do know his work um that
there's a lot to discover too um you
know we feel so lucky to have had the
chance to make it and to take that dive
and um and i hope that
because especially because of this
quality that we've talked about when you
watch silent films which is different to
watching films today i hope that you
know um that like me people will be
taking that journey backwards as well
james this has been a ton of fun um tell
our viewers where they can find the real
charlie chaplin yeah so the real show
chaplain is playing from december the
11th on show time and thank you matt
it's been such a pleasure talking to you
[Music]
you